das ist wirklich unglaublich und echt
kein superlativ ist zu übertrieben um
diesen erfolg zu feiern
ein forschungsteam hat es geschafft
lichtteilchen photonen also zu molekülen
zu gruppieren und dabei festgestellt
dass sie dann 10.000 mal langsamer als
licht sind die lichtgeschwindigkeit ist
damit nicht mehr unabänderlich
und diese moleküle interagieren
miteinander wie materie
das ist wirklich absolut und fachlich
wird das laserschwert jetzt realität
dazu jetzt alle facts in klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
an dieser stelle nochmals vielen dank an
die community ob whatsapp die sind
wirklich total gut unterwegs und finden
immer wieder den neuesten heißen scheiß
und das heer ist wirklich der absolute
unglaubliche sensationelle und so weiter
aber manche beschweren sich ja hier
da sich immer wieder superlative
verwende aber das ist wissenschaft
ständig werden neue beulen ins universum
getreten und es werden erkenntnisse
gewonnen die wirklich unglaublich sind
und das hier ist so etwas wirklich
absolut unfassbares und zu ende gedacht
könnte es wirklich so etwas wie
laserschwerter ermöglichen ja bei denen
jahr zwei laserstrahlen die massive
schwerter wie materie aneinander
schlagen licht verhält sich dabei wie
materie und genau das hat jetzt ein
forschungsteam gemacht photonen zu
molekülen verbunden und die verhalten
sich jetzt wie materie mit geringer
masse also der reihe nach vor einigen
jahren entdeckten forscher rund um
mladic vom mit massachusetts dass
photonen einen unmöglichen zustand
annehmen können wird ein schwacher
laserstrahl durch eine wolke ultrakalte
rubidium atome geschickt verbinden sich
einige photonen in diesem medium zu
paaren
zitat eine passende analogie wären die
aus science fiction filmen bekannten
laserschwerter wenn diese photonen
miteinander interagieren schubsen sie
sich und lenken einander ab die physik
dahinter ist ähnlich dem was in den
lichtschwertern ablaufen müsste das sagt
politik mit dieser erkenntnis gingen die
forscher einen schritt weiter wenn zwei
moleküle mit lichtteilchen möglich sind
warum gehen da nicht auch drei moleküle
sie verbesserten den versuchsaufbau
verfeinerten vor allem die messtechnik
und schickten nur sehr wenige photonen
durch die rubidium wolke und jetzt
passierte das absolut verblüffende die
photonen traten nicht nur in zwei
sondern auch in dreiergruppen aus der
wolke zitat das bedeutet dass die
photonen in diesen dreier gruppen nicht
nur jeweils einzeln mit einem zweiten
interagieren sondern dass sie alle drei
miteinander wechselwirken so koautor
aditya benkert ramani von der harvard
university und bahn hatten sie einen
zweiten unbekannten und unmöglichen
zustand von licht erzeugt und er ist
wirklich ab
frappierend jetzt reagierten die
photonen so träge als hätten sie masse
und ihre geschwindigkeit war 10.000 mal
langsamer als normalerweise bei licht
aber achtung damit ist natürlich nicht
die relativitätstheorie außer kraft
gesetzt der aufwand ist so groß und
diese teilchen herzustellen
in der natur passiert das so einfach
nicht es gilt also weiter die
lichtgeschwindigkeit ist konstanz raum
und zeit müssen sich um sie herum kommen
zurück zu unserem seltsamen teilchen
diese dreier moleküle entstehen wenn in
der wolke wenn die photonen mit den
rubidium atomen interagieren
das atom wird angeregt und bildet
zusammen mit dem foto nein polarion es
ist ein quasi teilchen energetisch
reagiert es wie ein foto nackt rum
hybrid teilchen wenn jetzt zwei oder
drei photonen solche polar itans bilden
dann findet eine wechselwirkung der
atomaren bestandteile stadt übersetzt
heißt das also atome und photonen
verbindung sich miteinander
womit die photonen atomare eigenschaften
übernehmen der hammer aber ist selbst
wenn die photonen die wolke dann
verlassen haben also gar keine polare
tanz mehr sind verhalten sich weiter so
sind quasi mit atomaren eigenschaften
geimpft was ließe sich nicht nur alles
mit licht molekülen machen was könnte
damit gebaut werden tatsächlich ist das
eine total irre perspektive gegenstände
aus licht vielleicht sogar nicht
schwerter und tipps dazu bilden sich
abstoßen photonen ein regelmäßiges
muster oder passiert etwas ganz anderes
also eine echte terra incognita also
unbekanntes terrain das hier beschritten
wird ja leute das ist wissenschaft hier
wird die welt wirklich zum teil neu
erschaffen und echt kein superlativ ist
hier übertrieben wenn er als erstes
neues zu den licht molekülen und zu
allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann
meldet euch hierbei whatsapp an dann
erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen
vom neuesten video eben vorab garantiert
ihr könnt dort direkt in der redaktion
von klicks und mitmachen und mit themen
vorschlagen oder andere vorschläge
machen
der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier
draufklicken und natürlich nicht das abo
mit genau der glocke vergessen hier geht
es weiter mit dafür draufklicken
schnellste kamera der welt lichtteilchen
in außergewöhnlicher formation
ansonsten würde ich mal sagen bis dann
bleibt dran